taylor if you were um asked to be
launched into space tomorrow would you
say yes or no no
that's what i said no hands down no i
said the same thing and he's like yes
you [ __ ] would what
why okay you got up that's how magic
yeah i'm mad right now okay what i'll
i'll tell you why okay because
inspiration four
all right
so inspiration
what's so funny it's a variation
inspirations for right
is elon musk's you know i mean spacex
program i thought you made a powerpoint
yeah the way you're saying i was like
holy [ __ ] no
no so the next the the next launch is
called inspiration four right i guess
there was a three before obviously not
five it goes in numbers right and the
four that are being blasted out in space
now right are civilians
okay right
these four
okay
okay right they're not astronauts this
girl haley the the white girl over above
in the corner right she was a cancer
patient
right he's gonna have to trim her own
bangs
that is gonna be rough
right and she works for saint jude's
hospital right wow and saint jude's you
know got one seat and she could they go
we want you to be the represent
representative okay so i would when i
was seeing this i go
i'm going to propose something to you oh
okay
i'm being real stop acting like you can
send me to space
what is it let me just let me just pitch
you on this thing i can't make happen
yeah
so elon musk i'm doing a proposal
okay dear elon musk all right i love
your cars is that good yeah right you
don't own one but you'd love to own one
my friend jean has one and it's smooth
as a river is that
i like that because they're rocky but
that's okay what rivers are ricky
yeah they're ricky they're [ __ ]
smooth as a lake it's smooth as a flat
green pasture there we go in in the in
montana exactly is that good grass is
not okay so just let's move your
topography is not on point it's smooth
as a baby baby's bottom there we go that
weird hollywood reference
[Laughter]
that is true all right so what i'm going
to say is um
dear elon okay
i propose
right that you do an inspiration five
it be the four
people
are all comics yes the four people when
they get blessed in the space are going
to do a space podcast so we'll sleep
there three days i think they're
spending
spending three days up there okay that's
it yeah just three days and we'll do a
space podcast okay okay
me
you're lunch you're putting yourself in
the inspiration fast you need an ethnic
yeah yeah you got to you need an ethnic
asian come on imagine if dr ken
got chosen
if dr king gets chosen before me
then i'll i'll be we'll do the
submersible in the ocean okay let's do
that we'll go deep in the ocean james
cameron james cameron
so um me taylor tomlinson
miss pat miss bats gotta be in there you
know miss pat i don't know her
personally yeah so funny and it's so
funny and everybody would want to see
her reaction in space yes
and
it would have to be joe rogan mark maron
i
who do you want mark i'm not going yes
you are
i am not are you kidding me i'm not a
good choice for a space podcast look at
the girl
look at the girl you're a hope you're a
hope
i'm still growing them out
dude no i would not be i would not be
fun and spit i would be like i would be
chilling in the corner like i need my
own room and everyone's like you get
this pod and i'm like that's not i
i need a i need a room guys oh all right
so you wouldn't want to do
open sleeping you wouldn't want to like
openly contribute to the group i don't
want to be there why do i want to all
right
okay so
unwilling people
what is that i find it to be so rude
what you're doing
today
i know i'm no budding instead of
standing yeah and i find it to be um um
preposterous is that right what right i
think it's preprocessors that you want
to go okay i just think that it's a once
in a lifetime opportunity right
it's something that i can say at parties
like i went to space you know i mean
it's just one of those things how many
times before that gets old though you're
like yeah dude oh there's bobby coming
the space guy yeah
why did we invite that guy is that what
you think
all right you're right maybe i would say
it five times perfect thank you gilbert
and that's why maybe you'll go too
you're lost taylor
so taylor see this guy right here
i i forgot this with generosity
generosity let's call it
chris you know how we gone on wow
his friend won the
his friend won the ticket yeah
and his friend couldn't go because he
had like a wedding to go to that's not
safe that's insane so he called them and
go can i just have my friend go oh my
god and he called his friend so i've
literally missed weddings to do the
schomburg improv
the fact that you would that's true you
go i can't i can't go to space yeah i
really want to
yeah yeah i got this wedding
what a great room so good don't you love
it yeah but probably should have gone to
my cousin's wedding
so i mean so if you you got offered
you'd have to what comic would you
replace you you get this you're standing
you're spamming
oh i mean it should be like another big
podcast person like this gotta be a
woman yeah like bring whitney up there
um
no what why why because
because we need age difference too like
how old are you taylor 27 right
you need we need a different generation
this is such [ __ ] this is why i get
so mad when male comics are like [ __ ]
women it's easier for women to blow up
sooner than guys and it's like i have to
blow up while i'm young otherwise
everyone's going to be like [ __ ] you i
can't like wait till i'm 40. yeah yeah
i have to do it right now well you're
like all right and then that's the only
way i get to stay so the idea that like